pbs news senior national security
analyst friend townsend joins us now
she served as homeland security advisor
to former president george w
bush fran good morning we just heard the
acting capital
police chief say that the threats are
through the roof
these appear to be based or prompted by
a baseless
conspiracy theory what what what
how concerned should we be by this
well anthony let's recall just last week
earlier this week actually the fbi
director chris wray said they have
2 000 open domestic terrorism cases
remember if
the fbi is saying that they have all
sorts of tools at their disposal
informants and cooperators wiretaps and
so it's entirely possible
that one of those investigations
produced the intelligence that we're
hearing now
that's been passed on to the capitol
police and as we just heard chris van
cleef say there are
conflicting messages among law
enforcement agencies fran
um what does that tell you
well not unusual anthony right everybody
it's is
it's the blind man looking at the
elephant right everybody feels a
different piece and sees a different
thing
i i have to say though we have to take
the threat given what happened on
january 6th
there's no not taking the threat
seriously yeah you mentioned
the fbi director christopher wray and
mentioning how many cases
there were out there how do we
effectively combat
violent terrorism within the united
states especially
uh with with the prevalence now on
social media
so look as the chris's package said
facebook and others are monitoring this
they're trying to cooperate with law
enforcement to the extent that they can
without interfering with free speech and
so
the companies corporate america is in a
difficult position here but i think
they're doing their best to try and
identify these threats
it's look this is a it's a much more
difficult problem
than confronting foreign terrorists
right americans understandably have
constitutional protections
and so the fbi has to have a predicate
in order to look at
activity here in the u.s that's the
right thing to do but
of course it makes investigating all the
more onerous
all right fran townsend thank you very
much fran